[Music]
slavo welcome to spectator TV now in The
Spectator this week you highlight the
despair of Palestinians not just in Gaza
but within the West Bank as well now
many have sought to explain the Hamas
attacks within the context of occupation
and Colonial struggle now in your view
as a philos ER does this despair ever
justify violence of any kind and in your
article you try to give this context but
does that mean that you're excusing or
justifying this violence
yourself look my position was here very
clear because I was accused yes that I
in a more refined Twisted way that I
somehow justify the Hamas violence and
then the idea was even no at this tragic
moment we don't speak about complexity
is just we should be shocked at what
happened I
agree absolutely but there is a but but
let's take I took the example of Hitler
my god there are dozens of books
explaining the background which was the
confused situation of suffering of
ordinary gerns and so on that was
exploited by Hitler by the Nazis to grab
power and it's for me a similar thing
that has to be done with the Hamas
attack I
unconditionally condemn it I even WR
Israel has not not only the right to
defend itself but also the right to
annihilate
Hamas but what really worries me is that
Hamas on the Palestinians side and the
present government of Israel on the
Israeli side are really doing something
that one cannot but but call following
that metaphor you know it takes two to
tango these are two radical stances I'm
not equalizing them in the sense of uh
evil and so on but nonetheless these are
two
comparable stances in the sense that
each of them wants to get rid of
annihilate the enemy Hamas said clearly
kill the Jews the Jews should be thrown
out the Jews don't belong here the
hardliners around Netanyahu are saying
the same this is primarily our land it's
exclusively Our Land
where does this leave Palestinians of
course it is pushing him to P sorry it
is pushing them to despair so I even
went a step further and said that from
habas we got a totally
inexcusable violent attack but from the
uh other side look for me it's more
crucial than Gaza look what is now
happening on the West Bank it's what one
cannot but call gradual ethnic
cleansing with constant violence of
settlers against Palestinians there and
it's not just a gentle violence people
are killed beaten to death and so on and
it's not something that is that happened
now after October the 7 it's going on
permanently
and even the United
States voiced their serious concern
about this so what I am afraid is that
both extreme sides hardliners in Israeli
government and Hamas are in some sense
echoing each other and objectively not
subjectively I'm not a conspiracy
theorist
they are uh supporting each other let's
face it the inexcusable attack on Gaza
served the government of Israel
perfectly to divert attention from what
is going on on the West Bank and to
proceed with much greater speed now
towards gradual ethnic cleansing what do
you mean sorry slavo what do you mean
the the the inexcusable attack on Gaza
do you mean the the October 7th attacks
on no no sorry I meant sorry the Hamas
attack yes yes yes yeah yeah to be clear
here which
uh again this is not as I was often
accused this is not just a formal
condemnation so that I can then proceed
to Israel bashing no I knew people who
knew people in who were slaughtered by
Hamas there as we all know the Paradox
is that these were people who
were absolutely open to Palestinians
having the Jewish settlers who were
slaughtered having contact with Gaza all
the time helping Gaza and so on and so
on so the message of Hamas attack was
clear
they were not killed because they stood
for the worst of Israeli militarism no
they were peac loving Jews they were
killed and the message was no peace with
Jews War to the end so again I have no
Illusions here about Hamas it's a
fundamentalist terrorist
organization but I think here problems
emerge that what is going on on the West
Bank especially for years now this
constant pressure and you can find
numerous
podcasts on uh on YouTube and so on
because Palestinians also have iPhones
and so on which make you
sick settlers protected even supported
by Israeli police and military units
terrorized Focus for example on a
Palestinian uh uh household on a farm
threatened them beat them also kill them
after October 7th only
over50 Palestinians were killed in such
operations and Israel does nothing so
here is the tragedy for me how both
sides raise tension of course by
endlessly showing repeating these images
of the horrors of the Hamas attack which
Israel of course has the full right to
do Israel what I'm afraid it is doing is
that instead of using this as a unique
chance of Peace instead of saying to
Palestinians Hamas is out but now here
is what we offer you on the West Bank at
least no they are using this
to to raise to a higher level the brutal
tension putting pushing Palestinians
there into Despair and what worries me
at least as much as this and here I
simply rationally don't understand what
Israel is doing it is that by this
inexcusably brutal attack on Gaza yes
Hamas has to be annihilated but the way
Israel is doing it with
exploding numbers of so-called
collateral damage children and so on can
you even imagine
what this is doing to anti-Semitism what
a new Boost this is giving to
anti-Semitism slav how is it possible to
annihilate Hamas as you say in Gaza
without when when it's such a densely
populated area and we do suspect that
Gaza that Hamas has crucial
infrastructure under civilian
infrastructure in tunnels in Gaza you
know if you're in the Israeli government
how is it possible to annihilate Hamas
as you say without that kind of casualty
I mean we now see that that kind of
bombardment has allowed Ground Forces to
go into and Surround Gaza City without
it the IDF couldn't be doing what it's
doing right
now oh no I I mean I know I'm not saying
it's an easy solution but and but to do
it a little bit more not gradually in
the sense of prolonging it for months
and so on but uh okay let me give you
one example you remember now it must be
already two three weeks ago when Israel
for the first time
po gave 24hour TR to citizens of
Northern Gaza of the Gaza City to move
South now wasn't this an absolutely
absurd proposal 1.2 million people many
of them in hospitals pregnant women and
so on cannot simply move to outside how
how should this be done so what I'm
saying is uh yes one has to destroy
Hamas but isn't there also a limit to
so-called
collateral
damage there should be a way which I
find even relatively easy
to to to imagine for example okay you
surround gas
then you establish slowly safety
corridors where of course you check
people and so on there is a
whole network of procedures which could
be done I think it's which could which
could make the operation much more human
otherwise isn't it a little bit too
simple okay I don't trust the
Palestinian numbers but for sure
uh uh many more people died in Gaza than
in than uh in the Israeli attack I uh
and on the other hand I agree that the
situation is complex how Hamas is in a
terrifing way using every people as a
field and so on and so on but isn't
there nonetheless a limit to saying okay
we killed one terrorist and I don't know
what would be the number 3040 innocent
Palestinians children de are just a
collateral damage it's a too easy
solution for me in a in a more gradual
way it could have been done you're the
philosopher here sorry you're the
philosopher here and what you're you
know you're talking about this kind of
calculus of how much lives are worth
what do you think what should be guiding
what is the balance to be struck here
when you've got these objectives and I I
hear what you're saying about the
Netanyahu government and I think a lot
of liberal secular Israelis before
October 7th would have agreed with you
on disagreeing with netanyahu's
government but what is the balance to be
struck you are you providing answers
here s are you providing answers in
terms of how yes in terms of how how the
should be dealing with but why this is
already typical why do we focus on
Gaza I think the real thing now is
happening on the West Bank much
intensified what what one cannot but
call ethnic cleansing there why Israel
one way for Israel to provide a
different message to Palestinians would
be to stop the ethnic cleansing on the
West Bank and to show that another way
is possible time to give sorry to show
that another way is possible yeah yeah
yeah this is the only way for me to
fully justify and it can be justified
the attack on Gaza at the same time you
have to show exactly the Palestinians
there is another way or as somebody who
certainly cannot be accused of being
pramas Yuval Noah Harari said we have to
offer Palestinians who don't support
Terror who are not anti-semitic we have
to offer them a clear way how to live
freely and in a dignify weight in their
own Homeland this is the term used by
Harari or look at what for example uh uh
other Israeli politicians more liberal
have said that the key the underlying
tension is the unresolved Palestinian
question on the one hand I don't buy
thiso leftist version of what Israel is
doing there is simply
neocolonialism colonizing a country no
Jewish people have a certain a certain
right to the land but not exclusive
right but so do Palestinians the only
way to resolve again the point is now
from the site of Israel to offer
Palestinians a clear hope not just to
put pressure on them and again I agree
with you it is problematic to uh to to
set a clear limit how much collateral
damage and so on and so on I'm only
saying obviously it could should have
been possible to do it in a better more
considerate way if for no other reason
for the incredible damage that this is
doing uh to to juice all
around can you imagine what impression
this constant image of children being
killed in Gaza and so on and so on what
they what they will do to the explosion
of
anti-Semitism slav I'm afraid that's all
we have time for thank you so much for
joining spectator
[Music]
TV